cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Let's jump to this uh the
story from the post millennial this is
this is huge
three men accused of Gretchen Whitmer
kidnap plot acquitted there you go I
mean what more do you need the last
three men who were charged in the plot
to kidnap Governor Gretchen Whitmer have
all been found not guilty on all charges
by the way William null twin brother
Michael null and Eric moliter were among
the 14 charge in the alleged plot and
three have been acquitted all three have
been acquitted Adam Fox and Barry Croft
Jr were convicted of kidnapping
conspiracy in 2022 the two were also
found guilty of conspiring to obtain a
weapon of mass destruction such as a
bomb to destroy a bridge I just it's
such obvious BS the general let me let
me break down for you how this works the
FBI finds some and then keeps
whispering things to him like don't you
want to do this come on don't you want
to do this and they'll be like nah not
really in the Black come on stood anyway
and they'll be like no not really just
get in the car and like okay he got in
the car that proves it and then yeah
this is happened in Ohio when I was
living there 2012 you can look this up I
mean it's just it is just like more
corroborative evidence that this happens
more than it's not like a one-off three
sentence to prison for plot to blow up
Ohio Bridge they were given explosives
dummy explosives by FBI undercover FBI
agents gave these three dudes fake
explosives and apparently colluded with
them it's the same as a controlled drug
by I want Donald Trump to criminally
charge all FBI agents who participated
in these conspiracies
FBI does is they'll set you up like oh
we have a cocaine dealer and they'll set
you have the cocaine dealer and the
cocaine dealers and FBI agent so I mean
it was all set up but we're never going
to get any transparency with the FBI I
mean I think the FBI and CIA killed JFK
I mean I I do not want Trump to go in it
should be like we're we're trying to get
that we're defend to get no I want to be
like whoa hold on yes yes but first
audit and criminal indictments for any
and all FBI agents who were party to
criminal plots and you know what there's
a lot of them we don't know about
I'd imagine more because you look at
what happens with the Whitmer thing how
many times have has the FBI engaged in a
conspiracy to say kidnap a politician
and then not convince anyone to join
them so we pulled those records and we
say ah we got an agent John Smith right
here looks like you engaged in a plot to
arrest a a mayor to to kidnap a mayor
and the black well yeah but we're doing
this thing well it says here you're the
one who initiated it put your hands
behind your back shut your mouth you
have the right to remain silent lock
them up
That's a hardcore dude but you know
those The Men Who were just what were
they acquitting they should be thankful
that the jury was able to learn about
these Rogue FBI informants because most
people in that position wouldn't have
that is what the FBI does yeah so these
guys have their lives dangling off the
edge of a cliff while these FBI agents
smirk and give the Kubrick stare and
laugh about it yeah I I am I am done
playing these games this is abject evil
there is no no legitimate reason for the
FBI to make fake plots and then try and
trick people to do them it doesn't make
sense these guys if they never met the
FBI would be sitting around drinking
talking smack and being and they'd be
worrying about football instead the FBI
comes in and goads them and coaxes them
gives the materials this is what we see
across the board with all these
different plots I say arrest and
criminally charge indict all of the FBI
agents because they are party to the
conspiracy you can't I think the law
should even be amended that says you
cannot charge someone
uh under this law unless the plan was
created outside of law enforcement if if
law enforcement agencies create the plot
then that should be fruit of the poison
tree and none of these men should be
able to be convicted that's like all
sting operations no it isn't no it's not
maybe no it's not wrong so I'll tell you
that not sting here's here's what some
of what the FBI has done
well entrapment is when you when you
knowingly when the person is being
forced to either by blackmail extortion
or otherwise but what the FBI has done
which is more questionable but not in
this territory tend to be a drug dealer
no they go to church they go they go to
mosques and they just hang up and then
they wait to see if anyone says anything
and then they leave and there are a
bunch of stories where I've heard I've
heard these stories you can look them up
where there were imams in like Dearborn
who reported the feds to the FBI
immediately when the guy came in and
said hey here's what I'm thinking they
were like oh okay have a nice day and
then immediately called the FED said
this guy's crazy get him out of here and
they're like all right all right right
they leave that is bad those are crazy
stories that cop that that FBI guy
should be arrested for doing that but if
all they do is we are going to have a
criminal informant tell us if
something's going on I got no problem
with that right we want to stop
legitimate acts of Terror what we do not
want is the feds creating the plot and
then trying to trick people into joining
it that right there at the moment it's
discovered who came up with this plan
agent agent Smith okay charges dismissed
Case Closed men you're all free to go
you've been Tim Joe Rogan talks about it
you know this in January 6 we probably
know this is they have agent
provocateurs where they can go in in to
a riot or to a protest and actually
accelerate things make things worse and
we never hold them accountable and it's
a it's an actual crime to lie to an FBI
agent well and and even outside of the
context of an investigation yeah so
Michael Flynn was criminally charged
even though he wasn't being formally
questioned that's ridiculous it's like
it's like you're hanging out he was they
were hanging out like a dinner or
something in the white house and they
were like so you know tell me about this
and he's like oh you know X Y and Z and
they're like we got him he just lied to
us that's it
yeah you're not even under formal
investigation if you lie to an FBI agent
let me let me I want to ask you Alex why
why uh how come Owen Shroyer is getting
60 days in jail
and the reason is the prosecution said
he he yelled death to tyrants he said
Democrats are tyrants and yelled at the
tyrants uh and Ray Epps who quite
literally said to go into the building
several times was charged with nothing
the the argument about the government
was Owen Shroyer didn't didn't go in to
the Capitol but he didn't need to the
people he was goading on did uh Ray Epps
is the guy who orchestrated walked
around saying to do it
what's going on well for me the biggest
red flag is when you see the New York
Times and you see Adam kinzinger and you
see all these left-wing people or Adam
kinsinger fake left Winger or fake right
wing or whatever you want to uh fake
both yeah fake both but my point is when
the mainstream media is running cover
for Ray Epps that's the biggest red flag
possible that just makes it seem like oh
this guy's definitely an agent
provocateur but with Owen I mean it's
his connection to Infowars they have to
take him down and they were not going to
give him probation they have to send a
message by making him go to jail but
what's ridiculous is Richard A Barnett
he's the guy that put his feet on an
explosion's desk I think he got seven
years yeah I mean when you're in your
60s and you get seven years I mean
that's that's almost life yeah and when
these guys let them into the building
yeah I know those mag walks you had to
turn off those maglocks but the cops
open the door there's what I'm saying
they open those doors
yeah I mean they're walking on Shaman
was just having a nice stroll it was it
was walking around confused and the cops
gave him directions and opened they
opened the door for him they were
telling him where to go but that's
that's an inside job and AOC is right
when she said that some of these cops
were in on it I'm like yes I think the
the Republicans should start arresting
all these cops and I mean it 100 percent
what what you need to do is stop
allowing the frogs to boil right all of
us are always sitting in this pot and
slowly slowly getting hotter so nobody
moves and then we go from in 2018
there's some street fights to in 2023
they've indicted the president 94 times
or does 94 charges on several different
indictments they're arresting lawyers
and journalists and it's just like okay
how do we get to this point it's because
it's incremental here's what you do
Republicans Matt Gates they won't do it
because they're like oh but we don't
want to piss off cops you in you you
immediately say we are going to uh I we
agree with Democrats January 6 was a
problem here's a video of the police
letting them in and and and helping the
Q Anon Shaman these police aided and
abetted the Insurrection and we need to
get to the bottom of this subpoena the
cops and then criminally charge them and
make them go into the prisons with the
j6ers each and every one every single
cop especially the one who shot Ashley
Bennett no questions
you just do it and then what happens uh
oh now you're going to have the Capitol
Police going to Democrats being like
what did you do with this can of worms
why are we involved in this and there's
not going to be a public you get AOC on
your side right away the first thing I
do is I go to OC and say how would you
like to indict the cops who helped the
j6ers she's going to say yes she's
already on camera saying it's a problem
then you put it in Pelosi's face and you
put in the democrat's face being like
you're right all of these cops that help
these people come in we're going to lock
them up too now you've created a a
problem for Democrats in that the Press
now becomes the Capitol Police that they
they championed cherished and celebrated
are all going to jail too
turn it back on them turn it back on
them
yeah but that's never going to happen I
mean well it's not a question of never
gonna happen it's I'm saying this is
that's what it should be done you know I
I tend to agree with you we should hold
these people the only the only thing
that's going to stop this stuff though
is I think is actually like abolishing
bureaucracy get rid of the FBI or fire
everybody
says everybody says abolish the FBI I
agree did there has been a weaponization
of our doj and all these three letter
agencies but how do you do that I don't
know that any president really could go
in and actually do it well uh wasn't the
FBI created by decree I don't know that
they're going to be able to dismantle
that the last person who tried was shot
in the head in Texas so what they're
going to do is they're just going to
have a and I wouldn't be surprised if
law enforcement this is probably not
going to happen very soon but just like
with covet how we had the contact
tracing apps they're gonna have like law
enforcement contact tracing apps with
the phone they're gonna be able to look
in your phone they're gonna know if
you're doing anything illegal they're
going to know the artificial
intelligence will be able to scan your
text messages listen to your phone calls
so we won't even need the traditional
cops like you think and it'll almost
need like you and social workers I mean
there are some good things that the FBI
does you know nothing good exploitation
no you know they they you know Tim
Oklahoma City Bombing not good I think I
think Ballard said he worked with FBI on
trafficking stuff I'm not saying every
FBI agent is bad but I'm just the
majority of their work no it's just it's
just a bad organization the idea that
the federal government needs to have a
police force like you you can argue that
police force for like Secret Service to
protect the the president and maybe for
Capital police and stuff like that but
the entire like all every state has
State Police and they're all capable of
working together they're all capable of
of sharing information it is not
necessary police are a problem fair
enough but he's forcing all the covets
yeah everybody's saying you're a FedEx
it's fine you're right and it's that's
that's totally true but again it's it's
still decentralizes the problem becomes
the centralization of power in
Washington everybody knows that
Washington does not have the individual
people or the state's best interests at
heart Washington is concerned with
Washington and that's the way it's
always going to be as long as uh as long
as power is centered there now I've
heard people talk about moving bureaus
and bureaucracies and stuff to other
parts of the country and maybe there's
an argument for that but really just get
rid of it get rid of it cut it out you
may abolish it it's a good point that
it's the dangers the organization of it
itself yeah the way it's organized the
centralization essentially of top-down
Authority that one guy known as Merrick
Garland or who is he not the head of the
FBI uh he's the yeah he's the he's the
Attorney General he's not the head of
the FBI but he's the head of the justice
department you get these tops giving
these author giving all the soldiers
basically their marching orders all
these Capitol Police are told let them
in we don't want him to break all the
windows just open the doors and let them
in so the cops stand back that's why I
when according to what how you were
saying Tim about arresting him I I tend
towards like what they did to the Nazis
is you arrest the ringleaders you arrest
the ones at the top and then the other
ones you know they're basically going to
be your soldier as well but there
there's videos of these cops opening the
doors and saying come on in I I think
that if we if the Republicans right now
there's a video of this say I want to
know who those cops are you bring them
in for open public Congressional
testimony say why did you open the door
and let them in let them say it on
C-Span to be repost and rebroadcast by
everybody on Twitter the officer says we
did open the doors then you can say okay
the question now becomes officer you let
them in and some of these people have
been in jail for two and a half years
how long how much time in prison do you
deserve for being the one who opened the
doors let the public decide should these
officers go to prison because if you say
no we must release the Jason
investigation because you could get
those cops and be like I was told by my
commanding officer by name
it would be an easy chain of command to
figure out how those doors got open but
I do want to congratulate the FBI on one
thing because they did great police work
when they found two passports on 911 of
the terrorists they weren't able to find
the black boxes but they were able to
find those passport so that was well
they got really lucky that they didn't
get burned up in the explosion I know
thank you they must have fallen out of
the plane before it hit the building
because they found it a couple blocks
away
I mean a lot of debris went very very
far that's true they were blown out the
sides of the buildings A lot of that
debris oh I mean in the initial crash
debris was launched like hundreds of
yards it's crazy but uh they were just
lucky that they they didn't yeah the
password just went through the nose cone
of the building and then two blocks down
the
you know why I'm really impressed with
that because I lose my passport all the
time yeah we need my own house you just
need to hire an FBI agent
to lose no but like I'll put it I'll be
like I have like I'll put in the safe or
something and then we'll travel so take
it out and then we'll put it in a
suitcase and then we'll come back and
put the suitcase in the room and I'll be
like wait it was it in the bag or was it
oh and I gotta tear the whole bag up and
I'm like no I put it back in the other
in the shop then I'll open and there it
is you know but it's hard sometimes
because you I don't use it that often
well call your FBI agent they'll know
well you know when uh maybe they could
work with that because they weren't able
to find the swatters who swatted us 15
times but but anyways the FBI back to
the main the main point uh
when I think about things like this like
hey bring in these cops and have them
testify how come how come nothing like
this ever happens even when it comes to
impeachment it is the most mundane and
predictable thing you can expect from
the GOP
there's there's evidence it's been
around for years that we've known about
with Hunter Biden in 2019 Politico wrote
Biden Inc we we we have that whole all
of it laid up by a journalist and now
four years later it's like let's uh ask
this question it's like where's anyone
to be like I am going to file a subpoena
for all of the police officers and make
them come testify I just
I really don't think
anyone ever does anything it's so boring
I mean I I gotta I just I don't
understand this man
about anything in life I I just don't
understand why nobody does anything and
I'm and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
say this to the extreme I mean this in
the most literal sense to the most
extreme degree no one does anything now
I'll clarify what I mean by that because
obviously we all do different things but
I mean there are prominent powerful
people with lots of money who you'll
hear complain and then do literally
nothing because you answered it because
they're powerful prominent people with
lots of money that's my point that's why
they don't do anything because they want
to continue being prominent powerful you
don't you don't lose that feeling
absolutely Elon Musk does stuff
and he's I I think it's massively
beneficial for him I mean granted he's
getting sued yeah they're coming out
from doj's coming after but they don't
do anything because it's not they don't
want to they'd rather go on the news and
line their pockets and increase their
net worth by 100. I think they should be
sent to the barracks when they serve an
office they're NPCs they're not allowed
to leave they should be in the barracked
they are NPCs and I tell you this
because
I know people who go on more adventures
and take more risks who are lower income
than wealthy individuals in this country
and in this world there's very few
people who are willing to take large
ridiculous risks in order to affect some
kind of positive change and it's like at
the top of my head who can I even think
of Elon that's maybe it can you yeah
but even he had I mean I like Vivek but
I mean he even had a pharmaceutical deal
that went bad so I mean he's not no no
but he's made a lot of money yeah in
terms of doing crazy stuff like big
boisterous things like Vivek is he's
doing something if he's saying he's
gonna end the FBI he's basically putting
himself in JFK's position oh I love it I
I think that's taking a huge risk just
so we can or clear Tim is not saying
that he loves the idea of vague being in
JFK's position specifically that he
would do that and that he's not in JFK I
love that there's a different place in
time I love that he's stepping up and
saying I am willing to put my face out
there with these statements taking all
the risks that come along with it
because it's the right thing to do yes
well outrageous after this pandemic and
I have an idea okay I just want to hire
a hundred clowns to like run around
Vegas
well how about we just how about Alex we
get you on 100 maybe okay maybe a
thousand we hire A Thousand Clowns
extras yes and you just they just will
do what you ask them about put FBI
informant in it don't do it yeah I know
remember remember when Oprah had the I
got a feeling song and it turned out
everyone in the audience were actually
dancers yeah I was talking about having
clowns to a street show to like be
comedic and and generate attention on
some issue you guys go to Dark Places
yeah inside jobs
yeah a bunch of clowns is gonna be like
it was worse than January 6th the clowns
stormed the building the makeup was
terrible I want to make this point
though is is it sounds so bad and this
is I hope it doesn't get me in trouble
but I've lost almost all faith in
humanity after the pandemic like I think
the Dumber who has the bigger the group
gets the Dumber it gets so that's why
like I'm almost empathetic to the elites
that don't want to interact with us oh
dude I I totally get more Bill Gates I'm
saying I give her Bill Gates he's like
just give him all the vaccines shut up
just you know go about your business
hold on hold on
anybody who's run a large company
understands the frustrations of what can
go wrong will go wrong and you know like
running this company there are things
that happen where it's like I am
genuinely shocked that something
happened like I don't understand how
explicit instructions of Take A to B and
then do c turns into X Y and Z and I'm
like I how did this how did this happen
and no one has an answer and I'm like
experiencing that I'm like uh so now so
so now I get it Bill Gates with his you
know how many hundred thousand employees
at a certain point his just eyes his
eyes are bleeding they're bloodshot and
he's like why did you put the mop in the
server room and it's just like I I don't
know CERN is
that explodes
because most humans we are I I hate to
admit we're all kind of dumb I bet if
you asked 10 people on the street
80 probably wouldn't know who Kamala
Harris is probably two people I mean the
majority wouldn't so people are just not
dialed in they're they're dead they're
you know have a ex-girlfriend baby mom
or whatever just they're they're not
dialed into what's really happening in
the world because they're so distracted
and we're all basically dead slaves just
trying to make it I I do in all
seriousness I do think people like Bill
Gates and a bunch of the other wealthy
powerful Elites
I I think if you were to talk to them
for one they're malthusian they do think
there's too many people and they will
legitimately tell you I mean I'm sure if
you're hanging out at Bilderberg with a
lot of these powerful International
Elites and politicians they're going to
say look man
think about how stupid the average
person is okay now realize half of them
are stupider than that and they vote and
that's like so that's half of that the
first half was George Carlin but that's
probably what they're thinking and
they're thinking we don't want stupid
people to have political power and so
what do you get
look at what's going on with everything
politically in terms of uh abortion
sterilization Etc this is not not a
detriment to conservatives who are more
resilient more uh self self uh Reliant
and protective of their kids it's it's
mostly detrimental to Urban liberals the
covet lockdown policies mostly
negatively impacted Urban liberals all
the things we see defund the police bad
for liberals conservatives and then the
people flee to more conservative areas
where they can be more resilient and and
you know resolved and then it is the
leftists who are suffering tremendously
under their own policies that's
resulting in them and then in them
having less kids yeah I I understand
that but you know people having less
kids is bad for society and civilization
in general yes but if conservatives have
twice as many kids which they're
probably going to start doing then
problem solved but we can never have
more kids in Venezuela's having I mean
they have a culture I mean seriously
they have a culture I doubt they're
doing a lot of abortion so if they can
just let people come in from other
countries my biological stepdad Tucker
Carlson you know gets a lot of heat for
saying the great replacement Theory but
I don't know it would be hard to debate
that if you really look at our
immigration policy this is a really good
idea powder PC says to send 100 clowns
to DC each with a senator's name and
badge and whenever they see the senator
they go there and they start dancing and
that's actually a really good idea to
just have like you know someone wait
outside and then when they see the
center walking the car the clown starts
is behind camera going like dude that
would be funny with kids and like the
value of having children
um equating to like the species
propagating I wonder if there's a
there's got to be a diminishing return I
I think that like yeah you can have four
kids that's maybe better than having
three but if you have 19 kids you don't
have time for 19 kids a lot of those
kids are going to grow up without a
parent so like that's worse the siblings
help a lot yeah in all situations like
in the past like people like families
have have had as many kids as they could
in the like anticipating some of them
dying off so you could you can still
manage to raise like bees that's what
bees do because they have a ton of
babies and then a bunch die but some
survive the point is though but like a
hundred years ago families were much
larger before any kind of birth control
people weren't like no we don't want to
have sex because we might have kids like
they were still getting it on and you
had big families and stuff like that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time